[Musik]
hallo in ihrem heute zeige ich euch wie
ihr die hot swing von kentucky fried
chicken zu hause nachmachen können und
das tolle bei selbstgemachten hot wings
ist dass die nicht nur richtig lecker
und wird sich schmecken
man kann auch den schärfegrad selbst
bestimmen wir benötigen 15
hähnchenflügel oder hähnchenkeulen je
nachdem was ich lieber ist etwas milch
mindestens zwei eier sonnenblumen oder
rapsöl außerdem ketchup ein paar gewürze
honig knoblauchzehen und cornflakes
achtet man den cornflakes bitte darauf
dass sie nicht zu sehr gezittert sind
die zutaten für die marinade müssen wir
einmal alle miteinander verrührt dafür
gebe ich als erstes die eier das öl und
den ketchup in ein gefäß und vor dass
mit dem schneebesen
[Musik]
den knoblauch 30 immer ganz gerne wer
möchte kann natürlich auch klein
schneiden
dann gibt es auch noch mit den zu gut
verrühren und dann kommen die restlichen
zutaten mit hinein
das wären dann einmal die ganzen gewürze
der haben mit salz pfeffer edel süßes
paprikapulver chiliflocken und curry ich
persönlich habe hier nicht so viel
genommen aber wer es scharf märkte
wollte auf jeden fall die doppelte oder
sogar dreifache menge nehmen
hier gebe ich noch den honig mit hinzu
wer keinen honig mag der kann ihn vor
auch weglassen aber am ende schmeckt
ihnen sowieso nicht so richtig raus ich
empfehle ich euch trotzdem rein zu
machen
zu guter letzt kommt noch die milch mit
hinein und wird gut verrührt und dann
ist die marinade auch schon fertig
[Musik]
ich könnte jetzt erst mal zur seite
stellen und es geht weiter mit den club
wegen konflikt wie später für den kranz
sorgen hier haben wir einmal die komplex
die nicht so viel zucker enthalten
dabei habe ich gemerkt dass die margen
cornflakes meistens 35 gramm zucker pro
100 gramm komplex enthalten und eben die
neue variante hatte nur sechs gramm
zucker pro 100 gramm und die würde ich
euch für das rezept auch empfehlen
jetzt werden die zwei stationen
vorbereitet dafür gebe ich die marinade
in eine tiefe schüssel und die
cornflakes in die andere schiffe unteres
geht auch super einfach ihr nehmt euch
eure hähnchenkeule oder hähnchenflügel
je nachdem putin einmal in die marinade
dann in die cornflakes und dann sollte
das ganze auf wunderbar halten und damit
doppelt knusprig haben sich das ganze
noch mal in die marinade und
anschließend noch mal in die cornflakes
und hier gebe ich euch einen ganz
entscheidenden tipp macht immer nur
soviel cornflakes in eure schüssel wie
ihr für einen ring oder eines münchen
keine benötigt denn dann kann das ganze
auch viel besser dran kleben dadurch
dass die auch trocken sind und wenn ihr
die dann soweit fertig habt könnt ihr
sie eigentlich schon fast auf ein
backblech tun
ich finde das immer noch mal ganz gerne
mit öl ein damit sie auch ja nicht dran
kleben bleiben
anschließend kommen die hot wings bei
180 grad ober und unterhitze für circa
45 minuten in den backofen
denkt bitte daran jeder backofen backt
anders und deswegen schaut immer wieder
nach ob sie auch nicht zu dunkel werden
und ich hab sie hier mit saurer soße
serviert ihr könnt natürlich nie was ich
am nächsten schmeckt
und falls jetzt auch lust habt die
kentucky fried chicken hot wings
nachzumachen
dann legt einfach los denn er gesehen so
schwer ist das ganze gar nicht und
meiner meinung nach schmeckt viel besser
als ich das video gefallen hat dann
freue ich mich sehr über einen daumen
hoch und wenn ihr keines meiner videos
mehr verpassen möchtest dann lassen wir
doch gerne ein abo da bis zum nächsten
mal